[Musique]
donc vous avez besoin que j'intervienne
je vais faire tout mon possible pour que
vous tombiez enceinte est-ce que ça vous
convient
en 30 ans d'activités j'ai réalisé ce
genre d'intervention des milliers de
fois
maintenant vous êtes prête et
heureusement entre de bonnes mains
vous êtes en saint à 100%
salut papa
la dépression prépare Tom touche environ
une femme sur cinq
le mental de la maman jouait énormément
vous n'avez pas à vous inquiéter Lucie
essayez de profiter de ce moment pour
vous détendre vous l'avez mérité
[Musique]
souriez Lucie
ça rend plus heureux c'est
scientifiquement prouvé
nous sommes en présence de jumeaux et
d'une fille ça nous fait trois bébés
mener à terme cette grossesse me semble
hasardeux
avec Kindle le courant passe pas
fronter tout ce qui vous empêche d'être
vous affronter ça
c'est ok c'est de me faire passer pour
une folle
[Musique]